hi guys my name is Karan Chaudhary and I
was born and raised in a small town
called footing Abad in India before
becoming an actor I was a Salesman in a
clothing store and I used to sell shoes
and clothes and cannot place New Delhi
and right after that I became a gym
trainer and I was a trainer for about 3
to 4 years and after that I moved to
Bombay to pursue my career as a model
actor and in 2013 I applied at the
Neighborhood Playhouse to study acting
in New York City so I moved here in 2013
since then I'm actively pursuing acting
and recently I started making my own
project last year I made a documentary
dedication and this year I made a short
film called New York I wrote it produced
it directed and acted in it New York has
been accepted in many film festivals and
we have won about five awards in various
categories you know what I have a date
today and because of you I'm - hey
alright I also got a goal I have a date
waiting for me it just gave me a deal
with the old personal problems later huh
my personal problems you're the one
who's causing these personal problems Oh
what are you blaming me for getting
yourself locked out of your apartment
you're a delivery guy you got one job to
do if it'd have done a job like it's the
foreword you could throw food like
you're supposed to you make a living
because of people like me
and you get to enjoy hot food in bed
because of people like me yeah where is
it where is my hot food I don't
know are you I just want to get my money
and get out of here hey Sun then the
more problem that I'm facing and I'm
sure a lot of people who come from
different countries are still facing
having to deal with their immigration
status people who come from different
countries and to pursue their career as
an actor in this country United States
you have to have the artist visa it's
really hard to get hard as visa and even
if you have the artist visa a lot of the
production film and TV both would still
not give you the job because they
consider people who have green cards or
people who are citizens of this country
so all that work that you put into
getting the oh one artists visa
it's always you
the only way to get the jobs and pursue
a successful acting career is to get a
green card and how I'm facing that
problem and trying to solve it is making
my own projects the faster you can apply
for the green card the better for you
and a way to do it is make as many
projects as you can take them to the
film festival let's see if they win some
awards you know get press for you and
then once you have enough projects about
yourself then you can apply for the
green card and the chances are you will
be much more successful the another
problem that I'm facing is financing for
the project I had an idea I wrote a
script and now I'm going into the
production but when it comes to
budgeting I was surprised that turning a
script into a film is way harder than I
thought so what I did budgeting why's
that my latest film New York was
originally written according to the
night night sequences so we turned the
night sequences into day sequences so
that saved me money on the lighting you
know there was a lot of shots of which I
planned in Times Square which is really
really hard to get along you know with
the equipment and the crew and
especially shooting and retakes so what
I did was I took all those sequences and
put it in a Greenwich Village streets
which are much easier to shoot much
nicer to you know look on camera and the
end of the problem was the crew so a lot
of the jobs were distributed to my
actors myself I was doing probably three
or four jobs on the day of shooting so I
cut a lot of crew and that saved me a
lot of money and that's how I was able
to shoot New York under a very limited
budget and in just one day there's
another problem that I face I'm sure a
lot of first-time filmmakers are still
facing that they have finished their
first film how to take it to their
audience especially to the film
festivals if you go and film freeway
sight there's about six to seven
thousand festivals listed each festival
would cost you
from thirty to sixty dollars if you
decide to submit your film in twenty
festivals that's gonna cost you a lot of
money so what I did
I wrote a personal email to every Film
Festival that I wanted to submit and
even more I sent a personal email to
more than a thousand film festivals
saying I'm an immigrant this is my first
phone and all I want is some sort of a
discount or a waiver and you would be
surprised what a success it was I was
successful in 90% of the time I
submitted my second film New York in 60
film festivals and 50 of those film
festivals gave me full waiver all you
got to do is ask because the answer is
always no until you ask thank you so
much for watching this video I would
love to know what kind of problems
you're facing especially if you happen
to be from a different country or any
other visa problem or if you're an actor
and trying to make their own projects
and the problems you're facing thank you
so much guys bye